rené dumont vous avez passé la nuit dans
le train
vous rentrez de fos ce matin dans le
très petit nombre de déplacements vous
avez choisi de faire pourquoi avez vous
choisi d'aller à fos fos sur mer s'est
tout même le symbole de notre
civilisation démentiel actuelle sur le
chemin de fausses venant de marseille je
me suis arrêté l usine bhl index ou un
groupe d'ouvriers immigrés surtout nord
d'afrique travail dans le plot sans même
qu'on leur donne le lait nécessaires
comme contre poison
il ya là une exploitation des
travailleurs immigrés qui travaillent
dans des conditions où les français
n'accepteraient pas de travailler
ensuite à fos sur mer
j'ai vu un complexe industriel qui est
vraiment démentiel les kilomètres de
tuyaux partout un paysage complètement
bouleversée alors que ce fut de même à
cette extrémité de la crau un paysage
sauvage et fort agréable
la pollution que commence à dégager ce
complexe va atteint des proportions
invraisemblables
on parle de 40 tonnes de mercure déposé
dans la méditerranée les superpétroliers
qui arrive jusqu'à quelle taille
acceptera ton ces superpétrolier
certains dépassent déjà 500 mille tonnes
ont supposant que l'un d'eux se déverse
dans la méditerranée c'est toute la vie
biologique de cette mère qui est perdu
le d'anhydride sulfureux so2 qui se
dégage dans l'atmosphère déjà 500 tonnes
par jour région parisienne en tout 900
tonnes 6 900 tonnes on va les dépasser
dans quelques années
certains pensent qu'on ira à 2000 ou à
3000 tonnes d'anhydride sulfureux
d'aidés versées par jour dans
l'atmosphère à ce moment là comme il ya
une inversion de température l'air
chauffé par les industries est enfermé
par un couvercle d'air froid que les
chiens parfois traverser parce qu'il à
côté le centre d'essais aérien d'istres
alors un ingénieur des mines consulter
dit
moi je ne sais pas où la de 2000 tonnes
par jour il n'y a pas d'exemple dans le
monde alors on ne sait pas du tout
quelles dégâts ça va produire mais tout
cela c'est pas seulement la fois des
industriels qui ne prennent pas toutes
les précautions contre la pollution
mais c'est aussi notre faute à nous
c'est bien évident mais ne pensez vous
pas que nous sommes contraints en fait
de construire si complexe géant elle
nous sommes contraints par notre taux
actuel de consommation d'énergie c'est
les usines centrales thermiques au pense
même mettre une centrale nucléaire
nous sommes contraints par leur taux de
consommation de matières minérales ne
sont contraints par notre civilisation
absurde de l'automobile individuelle
mais est ce que nous devons accepter
toutes les contraintes de ce type de
civilisation
si celui ci une mène dans une impasse
absolue si celui ci nous mène à la mort
le club de rome nous l'a dit si nous
continuons la vitesse de croissance
actuelle de la population et de la
production industrielle
c'est l'effondrement total de notre
civilisation au cours du siècle prochain
lors quand même est-ce que nous sommes
responsables de nos
arrière-petits-enfants
ou est ce que nous considérons leur sort
comme négligeable surtout même sérieux
mais la france peut-elle envisager de
restreindre sa consommation et de
revenir en arrière
on l'a dit souvent arrêter la
consommation et la production ça
signifie revenir à l'âge des cavernes
il ne s'agit pas d'arrêter la
consommation de tous il s'agit pas de la
croissance zéro il s'agit d'envisager
une autre croissance
il s'agit d'envisager d'autres
utilisations de l'énergie
répartition des revenus qui permettent
d'imposer d'autres répartition il s'agit
de rechercher d'autres sources d'énergie
qui ne soit pas importée la france a
perdu son indépendance puisque plus de
des deux tiers de l'énergie consommée en
france et l'énergie importée
il faut donc retrouver notre
indépendance mais qui consomme l'énergie
en france
ah ben c'est pas tout le monde on a
calculé qui a presque à peine 2 % de la
population française qui prend l'avion
l'autre jour j'étais à orly avec alfred
sauvy nous prenions la japan airlines de
paris à athènes un boeing 707
avec ses 5 dans la cabine de pilotage
avec ses 8 kiki world et hôtesses
étaient destinés à servir deux individus
mon ami alfred sauvy et moi même enfin
quel gaspillage d'énergie représente ce
déplacement d'un énorme avion pour
simplement de passage et on aurait pu
attendre nous faire prendre une autre
ligne vous avez dit l'autre jour au
cours de votre conférence de presse que
si vous deveniez président de la
république
vous feriez passer le prix de l'essence
à 5 francs est ce que ce n'est pas une
mesure extrêmement durs envers les gens
d'abord les plus modestes et ceux qui
ont le plus besoin de se déplacer en
automobile pour qu'ils automobile est un
instrument de liberté oui alors là il
faudrait revoir tout le contexte
évidemment j'ai eu un torse et de avancé
ce chiffre là sans avancer de contexte
dans lequel nous l'avions étudier
actuellement nous demandons la priorité
au transport collectif
actuellement nous rappelons à tout
instant que un passager qui va prendre
le futur train paris à lyon consommera 9
litres de fioul sur les 450 km de
distance
infiniment moins qu'une automobile à ce
moment là nous demandons que au lieu
d'avoir six voies de l'autoroute que
l'on peut remplacer trois autoroutes
ayant chacune six mois ça fait dix-huit
d'autoroute peuvent être remplacés par
simplement de voies de chemin de fer
aller retour de voix de métro aller
retour donc au lieu de 18 voix il y à
deux voix à ce moment-là nous demandons
qu'on met en place tout ce système
et quand tout ce système de transport
collectif sera mis en place
quand on aura étudié tous les problèmes
de l'urbanisme qui impose une
surconsommation
quand on aura étudié les systèmes des
grandes tours comme maine montparnasse
qui consomme à elle seule autant
d'énergie que une ville de 25 mille
habitants quand tous ces problèmes ont
été mis en place
quand les heures des travailleurs ne
sortirons tous pas tous à la même heure
à ce moment là l'essence consommée par
les voitures individuelles constituera
un luxe et à ce moment là on pourra
envisager une hausse pour réduire cette
consommation d'énergie parce que
l'économie française est obligé de
réduire cette consommation d'énergie
s'il s'agit de planifier la consommation
et la production d'énergie alors
pourrait-on savoir qui et comment on
produit l'énergie en france jusqu'à
présent en france
l'énergie est un monopole il y a le
monopole des charbonnages de france cela
d'ailleurs on les a abandonnés un peu
vite parce que il pourrait nous donner
plus d'énergie
il ya le monopole du gaz de france dont
une partie est importé importante de
hollande d'algérie ayant enfin surtout
le monopole de l'électricité de france
et bien c'est le monopole sont telles
que si vous avez et j'ai des amis qui
ont dans votre exploitation agricole
une petite chute d'eau qui pourrait être
intéressante à capter ou les abandonner
ses petites chutes d'eau elle représente
probablement la valeur de 10 milliards
de kilowattheures par an de gaspiller
supposer que vous installiez une
captation de cette chute aux un petit
moteur électrique que vous ayez de
voisins qui serait heureux parce que
c'est une ferme isolée
deux autres voisins loin de tout son
être heureux d'avoir cette électricité
vous n'avez pas le droit de le revendre
alors il faut faire venir une ligne
électrique sur des kilomètres de
distance pour desservir une petite ferme
isolée qui pourrait soit par le gaz de
fumier soit par l'énergie solaire soit
par le la petite chute au récupérer
l'énergie locales et se dispenser de
démolir le paysage avec ses pylônes
extravagants nous avons à repenser tous
ces problèmes là c'est bien évident mais
est ce que ce n'est pas utopique dans
une société moderne
imaginez un mode de production qui soit
complètement décentralisée c'est
justement notre société moderne qui nous
interdit cette décentralisation et cette
interdiction de décentralisation
apparaître un des obstacles une des
menaces les plus redoutables pour notre
civilisation
pensez donc maintenant nous dépendons
tous d'une société ayant chizé d'une
centralisation des pouvoirs et cette
centralisation poussé à l'extrême
paris quelque chose de redoutables à ce
moment là je pense évoquer une
comparaison entre deux pays socialistes
l'union soviétique et la chine en union
soviétique on a fait un capitalisme
d'état
certains disent un socialisme on va pas
discuter surprendre là mais on a fait
une société structurée
6es avec de très grandes usines
comparable à celle de nos sociétés
occidentales développé à ce moment là on
ne veut pas des hiérarchies c'est la
société
à ce moment là on est obligé de garder
la hiérarchie on est obligé de garder la
subordination en chine ont fait de
petites usines en chine on n'a pas fait
d'urbanisation délirante
en chine on a établi des processus de
production
chaque fois que c'est possible surtout
dans les industries légères de
consommation que chaque ouvrier peut
comprendre que chaque ouvrier peut
décider peut participer à la décision
alors voici une société d y arriver je
ne vais pas vous dire que la chine est
un paradis terrestre et que tout ce qui
est réalisé dans ce pays reçoit
l'approbation de tous les français non
mais pour ma part c'est un modèle que
nous aurions même nous c'est un modèle
qui va là plus pour le tir montre que
pour nous mais ce modèle que même nous
aurions intérêt à étudier de plus près
mais justement est ce que vous ne pensez
pas dans une société industrielle
évoluer comme la france il n'est pas
complètement utopique d'imaginer que les
gens ont installé les moulins à vent au
dessus de leur ferme équiper les shindo
et chauffer leur maison à l'énergie
solaire
c'est complètement utopique dans la le
climat on a créé actuellement on leur
dit que c'était la croissance qui était
le bonheur on leur a dit que c'était la
consommation d'énergie qui était le
bonheur on leur a dit qu'il n'y avait
pas d'autre solution mais regardons un
peu ce que c'est que cette solution
depuis trente ans on a doublé la
consommation d'énergie tous les dix ans
dont on a pu le faire trois fois oui
mais alors continuons à cette voie
supposons que dans les trois siècles à
venir
on multiplie par deux la consommation
d'énergie tous les dix ans c'est une
hypothèse on prolonge simplement la
courbe les scientifiques appellent ça
une extrapolation et 20 faisant un peu
d' extrapolations sur un siècle on a
multiplié la consommation d'énergie par
1024 si on double tous les dix ans sur
deux siècles on a multiplié la
conservation d'énergie par un peu plus
d'un million mais il 24 x 1024 les
écoles primaires ça faire c'est
multiplication sur trois siècles à plus
d'un million multiplié par mille ça fait
déjà plus d'un milliard alors arrêtons
nous avant
avant le milliard arrêtons-nous avant
l'hypothèse que dans trois siècles on
consommera un milliard de plus d'énergie
que aujourd'hui enfin est-ce que nous
sommes fous ou est-ce que nous sommes
réalistes
il faut être même le savoir rené dumont
vous nous parlez pas du nucléaire c'est
pourtant la solution choisie
officiellement et oui et oui c'est la
solution choisie par l'existence et j'ai
lu de louis puiseux un livre sur
vernement oui par le gouvernement et
j'ai même lu du directeur de recherche
de l'électricien de france un livre
intéressant la société post industrielle
la crise de l'énergie le désarroi post
industrielle qui nous dit ben il n'y a
pas moyen de faire autrement que de
passer au nucléaire bon pourquoi d'abord
n'y a pas moyen de faire autrement c'est
parce que pendant de longues années
on a refusé d'étudier toutes les autres
formes d'énergie et qu'on refuse encore
aujourd'hui nous avons l'énergie solaire
en provence quand même
j'en reviens le soleil brille et bien
aux états unis on consacre chaque année
5 milliards de dollars aux recherches
sur l'énergie solaire
parce qu'on estime dans ce pays pourtant
riche que c'est l'énergie de demain
en france on ne consacre pas le millième
de cette somme à la recherche sur
l'énergie solaire et l'énergie du vent
enfin je me rappelle dans ma jeunesse
les éoliennes qui était un peu partout
c'est jolienne sont démodés aujourd'hui
on a des formules bien meilleure dax
verticale qui peuvent capter des léger
souffle de vent et qu'ils peuvent avec
une batterie d'accumulateurs produire
assez d'énergie pour alimenter un groupe
de foyers domestiques et pourquoi cette
aile qui tournerait au vent ne seraient
pas aussi esthétique est aussi agréable
il y à l'énergie tugas de fumier on peut
tout de même recueillir toutes les
déjections des hommes et les animaux les
faire fermenter et obtenir ainsi comme
les chinois le fond obtenir ainsi du
méthane qui soit nous donne la chaleur
ou la lumière soit nous donne dans un
moteur à explosion l'énergie il y à
l'énergie géothermique
il lit à l'énergie des marées il y à la
différence de température dans les
océans toutes sortes de problèmes
l'ingénieur claude avait étudié
ces problèmes des océans tous ces
problèmes sont aujourd'hui négligés
pourquoi parce que les trusts pétroliers
pendant de longues années
on cherchait à combattre et ont réussi
efficacement à combattre toutes ces
autres formes d'énergie comment en
abaissant le prix du fuel et on a ruiné
les autres formes d'énergie à l'heure où
allons nous en fait ce qui est choisie
actuellement quoi qu'il en soit c'est
l'hypothèse nucléaire alors on dit qu'il
ya des risques considérables qui sont
attachés au développement du nucléaire
quel sens syrie via ces risques d'abord
ne sont pas tous bien défini mais ce
qu'on en sait c'est déjà suffisant pour
me faire redouter les pires catastrophes
prenons quelques exemples de l'énergie
nucléaire d'abord prenons un pays que
j'appellerais raisonnables où j'ai de
bons amis d'ailleurs la suède est la
suède avec un programme de construction
centrales nucléaires la première tranche
est en cours de réalisation mais il y
avait en projet une seconde tranche
en france on vient de décider de
réaliser en même temps la première la
seconde la troisième tranche
allons-y sans crainte en suède on
s'inquiète et on a nommé le parlement
suédois
une commission denquête en france on ne
les commissions d enquête qui sont faits
en partie par des gens qui appartiennent
à l'edf ou par des gens qui
appartiennent au fabricant de centrales
nucléaires et les appareils nécessaires
vous permettra d'être réservé sur
l'objectivité de gens qui sont assis
j'ai rencontré dans le train des
ingénieurs de l'edf qui m'ont fait le
grand éloge
bon ben j'ai dit écoutez on en reparlera
mais moi je vais me renseigner un peu
ailleurs
en suède on a créé une commission qui
elle est composée de savants qui n'ont
aucun intérêt dans telle ou telle forme
d'énergie
ces salons devaient donner leur réponse
au mois de janvier de cette année 74
ils ont demandé à ce nombre un an de
délai supplémentaire parce que ils n'ont
pas pu mesurer tout les problèmes
évidemment il est elle sans ces
problèmes la chaîne robe mais ce
problème surtout sur les normes
il ya toutes sortes de problèmes qui
sont ceux qui ne sont pas résolues
premier problème le refroidissement il
ya simplement que les grands fleuves qui
peuvent donner assez d'eau pour
refroidir la loire on a mis des
centrales à côté de la loire on n'arrive
pas
quand on leur a mis toutes les centrales
par front
grasset alors on fait 17 barrages dans
la haute-loire dans la hotte alliés on
nous a tous les bons champ des vallées
toutes les bonnes pris les vallées pour
pouvoir alimenter suffisamment ses
centrales nucléaires aux normes et
d'autres au bord du rhin et je serai
vendredi après demain à fessenheim avec
mes amis de mulhouse pour voir ce que
c'est que cette situation on a parlé de
risque quand même plus considérable des
risques d'accident les risques
d'accident s'il y a les risques
d'accident sont telles que s'il y a
quelque chose qui se produit et il s'en
produit l'accident et les compagnies
d'assurances refusent
lisez votre police d'assurance d'assurer
le danger nucléaire il y a des déchets
on appelle ça des déchets c'est les
résidus radioactifs
on ne sait pas quoi en faire on imagine
de la mettre dans la mer dans des fûts
on ne sait pas si la radioactivité ne va
pas encore rodé les fûts personne ne
sait rien de ce qui se passera dans cent
ans on est en train de jouer l'avenir de
nos petits enfants sur une série de
paris stupides infiniment plus stupide
que le pari de balzac
alors les flux sont encore rodé de
l'intérieur par la radioactivité
qu'est ce qui va se passer on les
immergent dans la mer la chaîne
alimentaire qu'est la brasserie immerge
plus la france ne les immergent plus on
parle des mines de sel on voit là cumulé
de quelle quantité qu'on ne saura plus
où les mettre
et puis on prévoit d'ici l'an 2000 deux
centrales nucléaires au bord de la mer
mais alors qu'est-ce qui nous restons en
ligne en france en france bien qu'en
france d'ici l'an 2000 qu'est ce qui
nous reste trois comme front de mer et
puis une fois que la centrale atomique a
fonctionné 25 ou 30 ans on prévoit de la
recouvrir d'un socle de béton énorme
alors qu'est ce que ça va être le
paysage des côtes de france où est ce
qu'on va se baigner quand même prenez du
mans si ces risques sont effectives
pourquoi est ce que les autres partis
politiques ne les dénoncent pas ah bah
ça il faudrait la poser la question je
pense que mes amis au grand jury
ici et là quand tu auras les
confrontations leur poserons la question
mais pour notre part nous ne voyons
personne
nous voyons personne qui leur répondent
correctement alors tous ces autres
candidats ne vous parle pas des choses
essentielles
on vous parle de l'état et de sa
souveraineté de l'état qu'il faut
rétablir dans un intégralité on vous
parle du bien public on vous parle de la
croissance on parle de toutes sortes de
choses sauf des menaces les plus
effroyables qu'on n'a jamais connu et
qui nous pèse sur nous alors quoi mais
rené dumont peut-on vraiment envisager
une société qui ne soit pas boulimique
en énergie ville société économique on
peut envisager une société où on
répartissent les lieux d'habitat et
lieux de travail pas loin les uns des
autres
et lorsqu'au moment là des distances à
parcourir soit qu'ils soient en
bicyclette sous un tramway sont très
limités tout ceci est réalisable
je vais vous demander vous même qu'est
ce que vous consommez comme énergie sur
scène elle sert s'il est la question
piège évidemment eh bien depuis que
j'écris l'utopie om heures j'ai remis ma
voiture au garage et je ne m'en sers que
dans les camps cas exceptionnel quand
j'ai beaucoup de livres à transporter
parce que vous savez les livres la
science c'est pesant mais autrement je
prends le métro et la bicyclette je la
prendrai plus s'il y avait moins le
risque d'accident
qu'est-ce qui nous
comme front de mer et puis une fois que
la centrale atomique a fonctionné 25 ou
30 ans on prévoit de le recouvrir d'un
socle de béton énorme
alors qu'est ce que ça va être le
paysage des côtes de france où est ce
qu'on va se baigner quand même prenez
guillemant si ces risques sont
effectives pourquoi est ce que les
autres partis politiques ne les
dénoncent pas ah bah ça il faudrait la
poser la question je pense que mes amis
au grand jury
ici et là quand tu auras des
confrontations leur poserons la question
mais pour notre part nous ne voyons
personne dans notre groupe nous voyons
personne qui leur répondent correctement
alors tous ces autres candidats ne vous
parle pas des choses essentielles
on vous parle de l'état et de sa
souveraineté de l'état qu'il faut
rétablir dans un intégralité on vous
parle du bien public on vous parle de la
croissance on vous parle de toutes
sortes de choses sauf des menaces de
plus effroyable qu'on n'a jamais connu
et qui nous pèse sur nous alors quoi